[Music]
welcome to Good Burger home with a good
burger can I take your
order welcome up The New Adventures of
AD and Dex starts
now oh sorry uh The New Adventures of AD
and Dex starts
now you think I can get a job at Good
Burger I'm putting a good word to Mr Jin
that's not Soap by the way it's maple
syrup why do you guys serve veggie
burgers I can serve anything on the menu
bur
Fri are you using a plunger to unclock
the shake machine as in the same plunger
we used to unclock the toilet uh no it
really means a lot that you came to see
me well you're my best
friend we're going to be opening Mega
good burgers in cities all over the
world from Hollywood to Hong Kong Hong
Kong is not a city it's a name of an A
King Kong the game with the paddles ping
pong the sound of doorbell ding down
what we shut down this door shut it down
shut it down I don't think you really
understand you're all fire I like that
fire fire it's hot you just got
hustled welcome to burer can I take your
order wa Mega Corp wants to replace
everybody with robots we got to do
something we're going to change the
world here's
your
[Music]
ask for no ice but there's ice in here h
no problem
dude I'll get you another
[Music]
one on the
E oh dude I'm glad you're
back